Well this sounds great.
Are there any down sides,
or where are you as far as
implementing this in your company?
>> So, we haven't implemented
it everywhere yet.
We're using it right now almost
exclusively for generating forecasters.
Although we've started using it in some
newer applications for similar variance.
We're not generating whole
applications with it yet,
we're generating mostly
components of applications.
So there's a lot of opportunity
there to expand its use and
we're looking into that.
Also, I think I mentioned that
this whole approach is based
on a lot of prior work.
In particular, it's based on the work
on these layered assemblies,
the GenVoca approach, the Head approach,
all the work of David Parnas,
Don Batory.
That work is quite rich, and so
we've been able to borrow heavily
from it to get the LayerBlox
to where it is right now.
But that prior work also has
gone on beyond what we've done.
So there are some pretty nice
things you can do in some of
Batory's latest work where you can
actually think about generating product
lines of product families.
Which, if you can imagine,
would scale much larger to
building whole applications.
We don't have any support for
that yet in LayerBlox, but
that's something we're looking into.
>> So
let me get a little clarification here.
You used the term product line and
product families.
Can you differentiate those two?
Probably the best is to give an example.
So what we've looked at so
far is how to use LayerBlox to generate
different forecasters,
different variants of a forecaster.
But a forecaster is one kind of product.
Often what you find, and
what we have to deliver to customers,
is a family of related projects.
Such as a forecaster that works together
with a replenishment system that works
together with a promotion
planning system.
And what you really would
like to do to scale this up
is to be able to generate product
lines of entire product families.
And that work is,
there is existing research in that area.
But we have not incorporated that yet
into LayerBlox.
>> So, there's this family
of compilers called GCC that
are capable of targeting
various platforms.
But also they can be used for different,
the technology can be used for
different programming languages.
Is that related to this product
lines and product families?
>> Interesting question.
Yeah, I guess you could say that.
I wouldn't think of a compiler
as a product family.
But to the extent that it is not for
a single language but
for multiple languages, like GCC can
be used for FORTRAN and for Ada.
>> Right.
>> Yeah, I think that's
probably a good way
of thinking about it.
>> Anything else you'd like to say about
the current status of LayerBlox or
the things you'd like
to do in the future?
We're interested in integrating
LayerBlox itself in this method
of composition more tightly into
the programming language that we
use to build our applications.
Right now LayerBlox is
a separate generator.
But historically, this kind of approach
has almost always started that way,
started with a separate generator.
But then led into very tight integration
into a programming language.
And I think that's probably
where this belongs.
That will then let us do much more
sophisticated analyses of type
correctness of these assemblies.
It'll help us make
some better decisions.
You mentioned the generality
versus performance problem,
which could at some point crop up.
I have no doubt that,
eventually, it might.
By integrating this more tightly into
the programming language, you get more
opportunities for having more context
when you're doing generation.
>> Is this anything like
the generic capability in Java?
Where you can generate collection
classes of various types by
parameterizing them?
>> It's very similar, yeah, so in fact
that tends to be that kind of method.
The use of templates that are supported
in the programming language is
often ways that this general model gets
tightly integrated into a language.
So there was some work, Janusz Mardok
just did some work on integrating
this very approach into Java, in
exactly the way you're just suggesting.
So yes.
>> And we will put on the class
resources page some links to some
of the papers that Kurt is
referring to in case you want to
look into them a little more deeply.